hey guys it's justine and today we are
checking out two things that are not
even out yet so sit down
get hyped we have two prototypes of
these mobile laptop monitors by mobile
pixels i'm gonna put a link in the
description if you wanna check out their
kickstarter and get all of the
information about them but i'm
really excited about this because these
new versions are smaller thinner lighter
and basically all around better than the
previous versions now i was so inspired
by
kind of their story of creating these
they've had several
very successful kickstarters and now
with the announcement and launch of
these
it's sort of the perfect time because
everyone is still kind of working from
home and i feel like that's going to be
kind of transitioning into the next year
and a lot of people have laptops but
being able to have an external monitor
or an extra screen is something that not
everybody has the luxury
of having but with this this is at a
really great price point and it just
attaches right onto your laptop and it
kind of gives you that flexibility of
using it when you want it and
not using it when you don't want it
thank you to mobile pixels for
sponsoring this video and getting me
these two prototypes to check out to
show to you guys so let's open these up
and then i'll show you guys in
comparison to the previous versions
what's new what's cool and we're gonna
test it out
also did i mention i know i didn't
mention because i just started the video
you can actually connect
your nintendo switch to one of these as
well i'm sold
okay it's unboxed whoa wow look at you
whoa okay that's cool that's pretty cool
okay let's open up the plus
[Music]
yeah that's cool
so it looks like these just actually
stick to the back of the laptop like
that's it
so what's cool is these monitors are
powered by usbc so not only is it
powered by it but that is how you'll
actually be receiving the signal they do
have
a little converter here so if you don't
have usbc
you'll be able to use just regular usb
3.0 and you'll be good to go
i just want to set this up on my
computer now like where's where are you
they did say that this will work on
laptops from around 13 inch to about 15
and a half it does work on windows
and mac as well so we're gonna test out
the light version first i am very
excited about the plus version because
this one also allows you to connect to
android phone it has auto rotation and
you can connect it to your nintendo
switch
let's try this one out first to get a
feel for how this thing works
so the screen on here is 12 and a half
inches
so it looks like we just attached these
little magnetic pucks
to the back of our computer we're good
to go so we're going to take off this
adhesive
[Music]
so now we're going to flip this over
we're just putting
oh caution i'm nervous
i think we're ready oh yeah
[Music]
okay all right it's on it's on
i get it that all makes sense
so you basically are just pulling this
out and then the whole thing just
slides like that this is cool
i used to work at coffee shops a lot
like i would take my laptop i wish
the coffee shops were open because this
would be me look at me
like i would be so cool like people
would always come up and say what are
you working on
what are you doing over there i'd make a
lot of friends this way i don't make
friends now because it's coveted times
so the magnets on the back are actually
sliding
and it's allowing this to come all the
way out and because
it's magnetic like we just go like this
like that's it oh this is cool
this is cool let's plug it in and try it
i actually think i want my monitor to
come out
this side it makes it so easy it's just
magnetic
and these are what is allowing it to
slide in and out
look look
[Music]
i have a whole side desktop now
hold on a second this also flips all the
way around like this
so if i wanted to show you something
look okay let me put a picture there you
go
and now if i want to get back to my own
content
i can it's also kind of cool because i
could use this
as like a little monitor to the side
like it doesn't actually have to be on i
just love that i can just
take this off and on so easily
[Music]
oh man let's test out the pro version
now so i like that this has two
additional usb-c
ports which is nice for something like
the macbook pro
13-inch because it only has two ports as
is so you are giving up
one port for the monitor and then you're
gonna need to charge obviously so
that doesn't leave you with a lot of
port options the pro version is also
bigger
and since we already have these magnets
set up we shouldn't have to
do any switching okay let's pop on this
plus
see what this looks like
it fits perfectly right over the top the
magnets that i already had on with the
light
they also have a really cool kickstand
accessory which i don't currently have
but that's also on the
kickstarter kickstand kickstarter it
also has pass-through charging so if you
want to plug this in to charge your
computer
that also works i really like this black
color it's kind of like a
brushed aluminum type look this has a
nice matte black
and the buttons on the side much like
the light version this is how you'll
adjust the brightness
of the monitor itself like i'm ready to
do business
okay this is actually pretty cool
i got a picture of me and maddie there
probably
you know if i was working i would have
something open here maybe some extra
footage
some graphics maybe the timeline or i
can have this as like a preview browser
or i could just be watching youtube
videos
while i'm working on excel spreadsheets
or a pages document or buying
bitcoin also don't forget this comes off
okay at my desk when i'm normally
working on my mac pro i actually have
one monitor set up vertical and the
other one
just regular horizontal like this and
that's mostly because i like to be able
to have
a full screen of all of my thumbnails or
if i'm searching through footage
this just seems like a much easier way
for me to kind of organize it i'm
basically replicating my desk setup
but on the go so to show you guys a
quick little comparison between the new
versions
and the previous older ones what's
really great about the new ones is you
don't have to install any additional
drivers
everything just automatically works and
these ones are so
much lighter than the previous versions
it's significant the bezels on the newer
ones are
so much smaller so you're actually able
to get a smaller screen
but with a larger screen real estate
because of these smaller bezels
i do really like the newer magnet
placement because they're like these
tiny little circles
whereas the older ones have these
rectangles and this doesn't actually
slide this gives you a lot more
flexibility depending upon what size
laptop you have
[Music]
so setting up the nintendo switch is
actually very easy so you plug in the
original nintendo switch charger
and then plug in your nintendo switch
using the usbc cable like i didn't even
know that this is something i needed
until now i have it
how did i live without it okay i'm still
wearing
my christmas outfit and my hair is a
mess
because i haven't played the game in so
long i'm wearing a happy new year hat
i probably have cockroaches in my house
look at there it is cockroach get him
get him
get him get him get him get him get him
get him squish
well thank you guys so much for watching
i will put a link in the description if
you want to get more information about
both of these mobile monitors this is
really cool to get a chance to check
these out before
even released so if you guys want more
information again link in the
description
and i'll see you guys in the next video